well president-elect joe biden is urging
congress to fast-track a coronavirus
relief package with the understanding
that even more
aid will be needed next month mr biden
acknowledged that friday's november jobs
report was bleak with just 245
000 new positions added last month those
are the smallest monthly gains since the
recovery began
back in may and the unemployment rate
clocked in at 6.7 percent as an
estimated 400
000 americans either stop working or
stop looking for work
in november nicole killian is in
wilmington delaware following the
president-elect this morning
good morning nicole good morning to you
michelle president-elect joe biden will
meet with his transition advisors today
and could roll out his
health care team as soon as next week in
the meantime he remains focused on the
economy and said
any action that congress takes now is
just a down payment
we're in a crisis as friday's jobs
report revealed more signs of a slowing
economy
president-elect joe biden said there's
no time to lose
and urged president trump and congress
to reach a deal
on another stimulus this situation is
urgent
if we don't act now the future will be
very bleak
americans need help and they need it now
the president-elect said he was
confident he could get republicans to go
big on additional economic measures once
he takes
office but he expressed concern over the
administration's plans to distribute a
covet vaccine
there is no detailed plan that we've
seen anyway
as to how you get the vaccine out of
a container into an injection
syringe into somebody's arm and it's
going to be very difficult for that to
be done and it's very expensive
while mr biden said he would be willing
to get a vaccine
he would not require it for all
americans i don't think it should be
mandatory i wouldn't demand to be
mandatory but i would
do everything in my power just like i
don't think masks have to be made
mandatory nationwide
he also acknowledged the pandemic could
impact his inauguration next month
including the possibility of scaling
back the inaugural parade
i think you're going to see something
that's closer to what the convention was
like
than the typical inauguration first and
foremost
and my objective is keep america safe
last night the president-elect announced
more senior staff to his
inaugural committee and he continues to
face more pressure
to diversify his cabinet the
president-elect would
not commit to naming a person of color
for
top posts like defense or attorney
general but he did promise that
when all of his picks are announced it
will be the single
most diverse cabinet that's ever existed
dana
all eyes are on him nicole thank you